[Music]
hey you guys
yeah it's monday and it really does seem
like i'm not i hope we're not jinxing
myself but
it really does seem like uh that land
cable solved all the problems i mean i
mean everything's just running a lot
that was a pretty good uh deal for
fifteen dollars
i had one for i had one before but it
was only 50 feet and it was like it
barely reached yeah uh all the way
downstairs but so i got a hundred foot
one for fifteen dollars and that's like
you know yeah so so whenever we need to
stream just i just plug it in which
means that
this will also reach into my place over
there i could use that to stream also
yeah
yeah i don't have to keep it hooked up
all the time because i don't usually use
this laptop except for streaming i bet
you that other little laptop will work
fine if it's hooked up yeah probably
well i could try i could try a little
stream
it probably will yeah but uh yeah so uh
if you weren't here yesterday we've been
doing the beverly hills cop trilogy
which tom got a long time ago and we
never got around to reviewing
so last night we watched beverly hills
cop two which i had seen before i think
i had only seen it once or twice
um but i remembered some [ __ ] from it
but uh yeah i didn't realize until we
started watching it last night
that this was directed by
tony scott yeah
[ __ ] uh what's his name's uh ridley
scott's brother yeah and i mean tony
scott also directed the hunger my
favorite vampire movie of all time he
also directed top gun which is how he
got the job on this days of thunder
which okay uh crimson tide desert
thunders wasn't bad
yeah well i guess because it was about i
guess because it was about nascar and it
had tom cruise in it i was like oh two
of my least favorite things in one movie
it wasn't bad
it wasn't very interesting
yeah that's what i mean so i was just
kind of like yeah he did crimson tide he
had a bunch of other ones uh sadly
passed away in 2012 and remember i was
telling you last night i was pretty sure
he committed suicide yeah he jumped off
a building damn in l.a damn yikes i
can't imagine
just going that way this movie uh
okay
the first the first beverly hills cop is
[ __ ] iconic it's classic i love that
movie uh it's got a really good
soundtrack with music and just a lot of
good scenes in it and it establishes a
really cool characters
uh cool characters across the board and
it's got a very fast pace
but visually the first movie is very
workmanlike it's not real stylish
it didn't really kind of have to be but
it's just visually not all that
remarkable
this one is
this looks like a ridley scout movie it
almost looks like black rain not quite
as colorful but
a lot of shadows a lot of depth and the
way things are shot just the way the
frame wait wait [ __ ] shots are
[ __ ] composed
this movie looks really slick it looks
good
is it as good as a story yeah
it's as good
i think this story is a little more
convoluted yeah it's a little harder to
follow i had a little problem following
it
but i had to ask jenny women hold on why
are they doing this again you know and i
into like i told you but i'm not
entirely sure i got all the details
either right
but um
you're kind of not watching these movies
for the plot with the bad guys you're
really just kind of watching watching it
to see how eddie murphy's going to get
out of these jams and how what what is
it he's going to say and how these
scenes are going to go down
and a lot of times that's not 100
percent really relevant
to the overarching plot behind the movie
it kinda
you can
what you can do is you can you're able
to watch them multiple times until it
just kind of seeps in of what happened
and because they were playing the [ __ ]
on vhs a lot too and they were planted
they played on cable you know if you had
hbo
so you saw it a bunch of times if you
were our generation
so you could kind of get away with a
little bit of a complicated plot and a
convoluted plot because you would
eventually see it so many times you
understood it
but this is probably the third time i've
seen it
with big breaks in between
and i liked it i liked it more this time
yeah i think i liked it more than the
last time i saw it i realized how good
this movie looks it's a good movie got a
lot of good humor
surge doesn't come back i don't think
that's what i was saying we were talking
about that before i was like wait i
thought surge was in this one but then i
was like well i guess there wouldn't be
any reason for search demeanor because
he works in that gallery and there would
be no reason for him to go to that
gallery maybe they thought that would be
like too much of a coincidence because i
mean the thing about it is that
i kind of like that
you know for a sequel they kind of did
sort of the same type of story in the
sense that you know eddie murphy has to
go out to
beverly hills and team up with his boys
yeah so partner yeah so how they set
that up you know obviously
you know it's a coincidence that
wouldn't happen that way in real life
but it's like that's fine but it was
different enough that you know i wasn't
really that bothered yeah you know what
i'm saying it starts off you know he's
getting ready in his apartment his
apartment's now spiffed up he's putting
on a suit they're playing cool music
he's [ __ ] kissing himself in the
mirror he's looking all dressed to the
nines get puts his gu there's a really
cool shot of his [ __ ] browning high
power sitting there on a damn nightstand
with the [ __ ] magazines and some ammo
around it and just a lot of shadows and
a lot of depth to the shot composition
the credits are rolling while he's
getting ready he goes out and gets in
his ferrari and takes off and
gets involved with these damn gangsters
has a little thing that meets this dude
at the down detroit bar and with and the
guy's got this blonde with big boobs and
[ __ ] he's begging on her in a way and
they're fighting and he's like i want i
need 1 000 credit cards he's trying to
buy these i think he was 2000
yeah
he's trying to get this gangster to sell
you know i can't i don't have time no i
need it now and it's just good it's just
good [ __ ] banter and
good scene you know
and it's just kind of sucking you back
into the damn axle foley
character it's
basically kind of a similar scene to
[ __ ] the cigarette
undercover deal where he was trying to
[ __ ] sell a damn truck full of
[ __ ] truck full of cigarettes to
these mobsters
and the dude from that [ __ ] heist is
there he goes i know no that's a cop
they started accusing each other
he talks his way out of that one
then he goes back to the damn
goes back to the police station and the
[ __ ] chief of police is chewing him
out again where the [ __ ] you ben foley
is it's just good he's like renting a
ferrari and like two thousand dollars
first yeah ferrari yeah yeah
i gotta look apart and i was kind of
[ __ ] he's got jeffrey and
jeffrey paul riser yeah yeah it's
effective so you're just getting
reintroduced
to these these old characters again
because
if you were a fan of the first movie
back in the day i think you had to wait
a couple years to see this one yeah i
think it was three years because the
first one came out in 84 and this one
came out in 87. yeah
so axel's not really broke like he was
anymore
he's evidently made some money
um
and or they're putting them on like
higher stakes putting them on higher
stakes uh
undercover
and it shows back in
back in uh
uh [ __ ] back in l.a or
beverly hills
bogomel was his name bogamill yeah yeah
bogamill good it sounds like a name from
lord of the rings yeah it sounds like
something from [ __ ]
the smurfs
the bad guy from the smurf that was that
was gargamel yeah yeah
bogamill gets shot by a big old tall
blonde
chick who's been heist and all this [ __ ]
and dinner and it's bridget nielsen back
when she was cute
that's a big [ __ ] yeah big [ __ ]
eddie murphy who goes into the whole big
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
a lot of that [ __ ] i believe was
ad-libbed because some of that [ __ ] just
comes out then
yeah they react to it yeah they react to
it like this the first time they've
heard it
you know so uh she's the big [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is that big you know just just
[ __ ] funny you know
and uh
turns out all these heists are happening
and she's kind of like the centerpiece
during these heists these heists this
big tall
beautiful blonde shooting the place up
and uh
their first clue
as well anyway she shoots bogamill
because he was closing in on the
operation
but he doesn't die
so eddie murphy hears about it all the
way back in detroit he sees it on the
news
so he makes contact with him he's coming
down there
to help
and that's kind of where this
story starts he goes back to
hollywood and he [ __ ] talks his way
into somebody else's house and just all
kinds of adventures and [ __ ] with axel
and if you notice this you know i was
watching this movie i was going you know
this is a lot like fletch a lot of a lot
of
a lot of uh axle foley's uh
uh special superhero powers is to lie
his way in and out of things kind of
like fletch
but just funnier if you ask me you know
fletch was a good movie too
i haven't seen fletch in a long time and
it's now i almost kind of don't want to
i don't know if i want to say this
across the board but i don't really want
to watch anything with chevy chase in it
because he's such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's a douche nozzle but nobody can
stand
he's funny as [ __ ] in his movies but
they say that in real life that dude has
like it's insufferable insufferable
can't be around it which is crazy yeah
that's crazy they just say he's a
[ __ ] dick yeah
you know that's what i don't know
normally everybody that i don't believe
until i see it but so many people have
said that that dude's a dick i mean if
everybody says
that you're a dick smack then probably
you are you know what i'm saying i'm
just saying
if there's like mixed opinions that's
different but
so
what ends up happening here is they go
to the damn crime scene
and it's kind of some there's some cool
gun
nut stuff in it you know what i mean
like one of the big clues that they find
is 40
44 auto mag casings
and they kind of tell the truth about
that
44 autumn mag was a custom wildcat
cartridge made for one pistol the
[ __ ] the auto mag pistol
which had a bunch of different
44 auto mag or that automatic pistol i
think it was one two and the three i
think there was a four also
some had different calibers but the main
one was auto mag 44 auto mag
and what you do is you take a 308 rifle
case and cut it down and put a
44 caliber bullet in the end of it and
[ __ ] hand load it and
it was powerful it's kind of like 44
magnum
but it was better than 44 magnum
for an automatic pistol
until the desert eagle was out you know
you could shoot 44 magnum through that
but they had to do some engineering
black backflips to get 44 magnum to go
through that
because it was a 44 magnum's a rimmed
case it's for revolvers it was never
designed to work in an automatic
pistol so 44 auto mag was a way of
getting around that to make a truly
automatic 44 magnum cartridge
which he would and it worked great but i
don't know why it wasn't a commercial
success
i guess because the 44 desert eagle was
so popular and that one was shooting 44
magnum so
people just went with that you know 44
magnum was easy was already in
production but 44 automatic mostly had
to be made by hand
people didn't want to go through the
trouble i guess
which to me that seemed like the one
kind of uh
weak point in their operation yeah was
that why would you use a wildcat
cartridge why would you use such a
distinctive
cartridge when you're doing these
because it could easily i mean that's
like it immediately gets like traced
back to them yeah the reason why they
did that is because these are california
guys making these movies
and they're trying to damn
make the bad guys special
so therefore the bad guys have to be
using special equipment
[ __ ] that you can't get anywhere else
that's that might impress an audience
but that wouldn't impress
professional thieves they would use the
most commonly available [ __ ]
you can see that's what i'm saying but
target yourself now they did like
address that in the movie uh when he
when uh jurgen proc now was talking to
dean stockwell's character um they did
like address that it's like did you
actually like i don't think that dean
stockwell's character i don't think he
was supposed to use those yeah like do
you think they couldn't find you with
that um yeah so it's just kind of like
so that was just like a [ __ ] up so they
did like acknowledge but i think they
wrote it like that too just so it'd be
easier
for
uh for them to find that distinctive
cartridge and then for
for them to be like oh i know this gun
expert that maybe knows where that came
from and then like it it saved a lot of
time yeah i guess so it was like an
efficient way of them getting onto the
people early in this particular
environment and this story that clue led
to the beverly hills gun club yeah
because
in california in that area
that's what that's where those guys
would be they'd
they'd be rich guys in that gun club
maybe you could figure out who made that
that casing because you have to make the
case
then load it
not difficult to do i've done stuff like
that not not with 44 auto mag but with
other cartridges making wildcats
you're done with hand tools you just got
to buy them so it's not rocket science
and you got to have the right loading
manuals and measuring tools
but um
you know it's just a little detail they
put in movies and guys that are in the
guns [ __ ] we kind of like that [ __ ]
but we also kind of scoff on her like
yeah why would you use that
shouldn't use nine millimeter those
things are well yeah like i said i i do
i do like though that they did address
that yeah yeah like as though you know
you weren't really supposed to do that
and we did it like we weren't thinking
about it like a lower level person
didn't you're not thinking about it yeah
and the 44 automatic is a gigantic
[ __ ] gas operated pistol not
practical not for you you can't con you
can't conceal it it was made for [ __ ]
big game
big game and [ __ ] talking look what i
got
you know but yeah i mean i did like like
i said the the plot structure of this
one is pretty much just like the first
one like i said they set up with eddie
murphy still back in uh detroit like
doing an undercover job it's just like a
fancier one yeah and then he gets called
back to beverly hills to
investigate in this case like the
shooting of his friend at least like
bogamill he didn't die but um you know
he's kind of like laid up for the whole
movie so he just does go undercover and
i like that they added like a couple new
elements like
um you know like rosewood and uh and
taggart them being like uh kind of on
the outs because there's a new chief of
police who doesn't like them very much
so uh so there's like another hurdle
that they have to get around i like that
they expanded rosewood's character judge
reinhold's character
out from
sort of being like this goofy
dim bulb a little bit
um they kind of like expanded his
character some and made him kind of like
grow a pair toward the end i also really
liked when they went to his apartment
and it's like he had like the cobra
poster which like i said was kind of a
call rambo and cobra yeah yeah and it
was like filled with plants yeah and
guns yeah and guns and for some reason
one of the funniest things in there to
me was that whole thing with the turtle
yeah big al yeah big and eddie murphy
asking where the turtles dick was yeah
yeah and then judge reinhold getting his
feelings all hurt like you know where
your dick is don't you
i don't know why that baby laughs
somewhere because the turtle's like oh
my god i don't know what's going on yeah
the significant
the significance of the cobra poster if
you guys didn't see our other review of
yesterday
or part one or beverly hills cop
beverly hills cop originally
was gonna be um a sylvester stallone
movie and stallone
liked it but he wanted to make certain
changes he wanted the dude's name to be
cabretti he wanted him to be very
italian and didn't want so much humor in
it and wanted more action
and they were like no sorry uh not this
movie but somebody over with somebody in
that company is like i'll do that movie
with you we'll call it cobra
so cobra is a
revamped beverly hills cop
for sylvester stallone
so
they homaged it in this movie they they
put a cobra poster in there
and yeah in general yeah like in his
bedroom was it it was in his bedroom
yeah
and they made sure to like that living
room no because i think yeah the living
room was where all yeah because he went
in the bedroom and then he went like
that and they're all his guns in the
back of the door and like that was like
kind of a running gag that judge
reinhold even though he seemed like this
kind of weedy little dork or whatever
like he had there was all these guns in
his apartment and then like is the trunk
of his car like he had like [ __ ] guns
in there and [ __ ] like that well he was
kind of like
becoming more of what he was yeah he was
getting more green
more plant-friendly more creature
friendly and with animals and all this
kind of stuff but more into guns more
firepower
more just more more of what he was
and he like kind of learned to stand up
for him yeah he learned to stand up
right like
say that he had magnified his
[Laughter]
and what's funny is they look on the
back of the door he had hanging up on
the back of the door more guns but they
were all revolvers that was another
funny thing too yeah the revolvers were
just bigger
more
you didn't go to automatics or anything
like that just no bigger and bigger
revolvers which is kind of funny if
you're a gun guy you're like yeah okay
because i needed more firepower he's got
like i don't know huge 44 magnum that's
not what firepower means but you know
okay
firepowers how much ammo you're carrying
is more than anything you know
but you know
i i just like that they still carry in
six rounds and i like that they kind of
did a little bit of stuff with taggart
too where his because his wife had left
him so he was kind of like uh glum
but then he was like afraid that they
were he was going to get in trouble like
working with axel foley again and then
after a while he was just like you know
what [ __ ] it
i don't care if i get fired i don't care
if i lose my medical insurance i don't
care if he's like you know the chief of
police hates us anyway we're probably
gonna get fired anyway so we might as
well because they had already like
bumped him down to traffic cops because
they were investigating some [ __ ] or
they did something they weren't supposed
to do
and uh yeah so so i like that they kind
of brought that new
uh conflict in there i gotta say though
it's like like i said serge wasn't in it
and also jenny from the first movie
wasn't it like i said i guess it was
this was a different story yeah but they
weren't really necessary they weren't
really yeah because because jenny that
was um you know that was
alex foley's friend yeah but i mean i
don't know it's i kind of wish they
would have mentioned it but like i said
it didn't have anything to do with the
gallery where she worked
um so i guess that it would it's kind of
strange though because she lived in the
area she you'd think that he would have
visited her that he would that's what i
was thinking it's like he could have
called us up and said hey bogamill got
shot or she could have called and told
him right that would have made more
because that seems more plausible to me
than seeing it on the news maybe they
couldn't get her
that's what i mean maybe maybe she
didn't that was another thing too that i
thought was a little weird okay so while
he was in detroit he sees the news that
like bogamill got shot in la which is
not
crazy that they would put that on the
news like a cop like uh
yeah but i'm just saying that i think it
was a little too coincidental that he
would have i would have liked it better
if she could jenny had called him or if
the daughter had called him yeah because
he did actually like call the daughter
and talk to her and she was kind of like
a big character later yeah there's a
bunch of scenes in this with uh eddie
murphy uh basically telling [ __ ] uh
uh [ __ ] bogamill that hey you know if
i can you know i mean i might have to
date your daughter and then him kind of
flirting with the daughter and comforter
at the same time that's kind of funny
because uh eddie murphy uh you know by
the time this movie had come out eddie
murphy on saturday night live and
everything did a lot of skits about
him being a ladies man which evidently
was true uh yeah he was very popular
very popular with the women he would
joke about his popularity
but uh yeah so that's in there there's
just a lot of good [ __ ] in the movie i
mean other than the turtle thing i think
my other favorite scene is him totally
talking his way into that
house
like just because he doesn't want to
stay in a hotel i'm guessing yeah so he
just sees this house that's kind of like
under construction borrows the house and
he basically yeah
there's not just any rights
there and like there's like a crew and
he just comes and says he's the bill
they get spectacular yeah yeah and he's
like these are the wrong plans either
what are you doing stop
it's not your fault boys it's not your
fault give yourself away this is not
supposed to have any right angles yeah
no right angles it's going to be right
as a donut because what are you an art
critic now
because they were going to be gone for a
week they were in hawaii and so he was
just kind of like well i'm gonna get
this sorted out so you guys just all go
home you got to wake up
stays in the house
this [ __ ] was funny yeah i liked that
scene too that was like super funny but
yeah um yeah this had like a lot of the
similar kind of thing like i said the
only criticism
i have is like the story was a little
more convoluted i don't really think it
needed to be that convoluted because
i honestly i don't even think it needed
the arms dealer thing or it needed only
the arms dealer thing i don't think it
needed the arms dealer thing
and the insurance fraud right and the
alphabet uh you know
they weren't killings the alphabet
robberies or whatever like the high-end
robberies like the jewelry stores and
stuff um i kind of think they could have
streamlined that a little bit because
like i said it got a little bit
convoluted yeah like i got it i got what
was going on but i'm like that seems
like a really complicated way to make
money yeah
they basically should have been kind of
like uh
the guys from the first movie or maybe
the bad guys from [ __ ] die hard
should have been a situation like that
where it was pretty simple
yeah with uh some good bad guy
characters with that you know what i
mean that you could play with before
they got killed or arrested that's right
it was a little bit convoluted i think
you're right
you know what they it doesn't matter
though no not really like i said that's
a very very small criticism that that
and like i wish they would have set up
him coming to um to beverly hills like
in a more in a less like sort of clunky
way instead of seeing it on the news no
it should have been jenny called which
it should have been jenny or uh or
bogamill's daughter
calling him yeah because you would think
yeah because they were supposed to go
fishing remember and then bogamill said
oh i can't go fishing i got this thing
and then he got shot yeah so you'd think
that the daughter would have called him
yeah and said hey my dad got shot right
what else could have called him billy
would have called him yeah that's what
i'm saying a lot of it was women would
have called and told him like in instead
of him seeing it on the taggart would
have said no we'll let our local guys
handle it but billy was the kind of
character well i think we should call
axel maybe that's like some [ __ ] yeah to
me that would have that would have made
a lot that made more sense because even
though like i said a high ranking cop
getting shot like that in broad daylight
um
would have made national news
it just to me it seemed like a little
unbelievable that he would have just
happened to be watching the news and
seen that yeah so and you know there
there's a lot of characters that could
have called him and it would have been
like a lot more believable yeah so
there's that and like i said just but i
did like the other stuff that they added
i liked
gilbert gottfried was in there too i
think you were in the bathroom during
that part
because he was one he was like the
lawyer
of the guy
but yeah i just he was like yeah he was
like in one scene and like they went
into his office and like told him he had
like all these unpaid parking tickets
yeah and then said they were gonna
arrest him and then like but they got
him to like leave so he could use their
computer so they could figure out like
where this dude's money was going i'm
gonna say technically
and just visually this is a superior
movie to the first one it's much nicer
looking it's a lot more stylish it looks
more like a noir like i said it looks
like you know it's tony scott so it
looks like that it's like tony's got
ridley's got kind of look too along the
lines of black rain
it you know what the one scene toward
the end you know when they were having
like the big shootout with the bad guys
like in that big barn uh you know where
all the arms were the fights and the
shootouts are much better yeah yeah that
scene that where there was like all this
sort of like fabric or plastic like
raggedy looking plastic like hanging
down and all the pigeons and like the
kind of like hazy yeah it reminded me
well it reminded me of the end of the
hunger yeah like that attic room with
like that one beam of light coming down
and like all the all the fabric tattery
fabric and the birds so visually you got
[ __ ] the hunger black rain and blade
runner kinda
it's it's what it kind of looked like a
lot of shadows and lines and black lines
and shadows going across people so you
have depth to the shots it just looks a
lot better
yeah i mean visually it is much nicer
and the fight scenes choreographed and
edited a lot better
uh it's
just the action looks a lot better
yeah i mean car chases and everything
and it's still funny it still has that
you know eddie murphy magic in it
because like i said that's sort of right
uh what you want to see like in these
kind of movies you kind of want to see
how he's going to talk his way out of
shape yeah with a film noir detective
[ __ ]
motif over it that [ __ ] it works
it doesn't look depressing but it looks
serious it looks good and also there's
uh i think they did because obviously
you had to have a scene in a strip club
because you know they had that the first
one and you had a you had a scene at the
playboy mansion yeah with a cameo by
hugh hefner yeah he's in it
who comes over and kicks everybody out
seeing those old 80s
[Laughter]
seeing those old 80s strippers man you
you you [ __ ] reminds me of
of the popular body styles back then
were
just very skinny man
skinny lots of wind straw
almost asexual looking beautiful i mean
not as long as narrow hips i feel like
it wasn't as skinny as the 70s yeah but
it's still i mean but it's still pretty
it's getting yeah
yeah uh you look at them like this kind
of scrawny
yeah i mean because i feel like in the
70s they liked them like super super
scrawny whereas in the 80s they're like
well scrawny but with big tits you're
right
they said those narrow hips and long
kind of shapeless legs you know it was
kind of weird and then they had
desperate definition the signs of
[ __ ] that they were taking winstrol
because you know
l.a you know the la area is just real
close to [ __ ] tijuana so that you're
getting all your damn anabolics there's
a reason why
muscle beach in [ __ ] arnold
schwarzenegger where all came out of
gold's gym because it's right there
near [ __ ] tijuana where all the
steroids came from they got good [ __ ]
there
been making it for [ __ ] ever that's
it's easy to make
yup but that's why muscle beaches was
there and why it wasn't in say [ __ ]
canada
[Laughter]
but yeah i mean seeing this one again
like i said i had seen this one once or
twice before
i think i did like it better this time
it's weird because i mean the first
movie when the first movie came out in
84 it was like pretty much universally
beloved this one seemed like it got a
lot more mixed reviews um some people
were kind of like well it's just the
story is pretty much the same as the
first one it's not quite as funny um but
you know some people liked it i feel
like time has been kind to it and i feel
like most of the reviews i've seen that
are recent are a lot more positive with
most people saying it's easily as good
if not or better than the second one
than the first one um i think other than
a little better man um i still like the
first one better i think the first one's
a little bit funnier and like i said i
think it's because
i think it's just mostly because the
story is too convoluted i don't even
care if the story is like similar to the
first one like the structure i don't
give a [ __ ] about that i just think they
could have like streamlined the story a
little bit because i kind of feel like
the whole criminal uh plot that they had
going on was just too complicated like i
knew what was going on but i was just
kind of like this is like way too many
hoops for me to have to jump through to
like figure this out um you know so if
they could have simplified that and just
you know
i think that it would have been probably
better
and they're both great movies the first
is a [ __ ] classic yeah it just is
but i think the second one is a better
product it's just better like it's
better looking better looking now i will
say the soundtrack in the second one
isn't as good not quite they do use axle
f the harold baltimore uh theme song and
the twitter sisters had a song in it but
it wasn't as iconic i remembered most of
the songs i mean shakedown that's
[ __ ] bob seeger your favorite yeah
yeah um
yeah he hates pogba
so
it's an okay song
yeah but it's it's an ear worm that
that's the song that i remember the most
there was a song on there by the jets
that i think i kind of vaguely rose like
ah yeah that sounds familiar um but it's
weird because when we re-watched the
first movie i was like i remembered
every single song yeah like all the
words and everything the second one i
think i only remembered like shakedown
and one of the other ones yeah so it
wasn't quite as iconic um it did do
pretty well i remember but uh the movie
like i said even though it got mixed
reviews i mean so many people were like
looking forward to this because it had
been three years
um it didn't make quite as much as the
first one but it still made a [ __ ] ton
of money i think it ended up being the
second or third highest grossing film in
the world that year i think it was
second highest grossing i think fatal
attraction was the first was the highest
but it was like right behind that
so
good flick not too bad it's not too bad
now we're gonna do this third one too
we'll watch it tonight we're gonna watch
the third one tonight and then now i
don't think that i've ever seen the
third one i could be wrong about that
because i saw a little i've only seen it
a couple times and uh um the last time i
tried to watch it was a couple years
back when i bought this set i got
about 30 minutes into it and it felt so
off i i had to get up and go do
something when i got back i said i want
to finish it never finished it
but i remember even back in the day not
really liking the third one that much i
kind of feel like a lot of people don't
like the third one yeah um i'm not
judging i haven't seen it i don't think
i don't remember i remember it feeling
very disjointed
badly edited
not real funny kind of stale
but we'll see and i remember it looking
like [ __ ] basically look real i mean it
was several years later i don't i mean
part three didn't come out to what 1994
or something or was it earlier i don't
know i kind of feel like it was a while
like before the third one came out yeah
but
we're doing this series because i've
heard rumors has it is that
the next eddie murphy movie will be a
axophobia movie we'll see but that
that's just a rumor
but it makes sense it makes sense that
that's what he would do next i mean that
does seem like a project and it's gonna
have to be good
you know yeah it better be yeah
and hey dolomites my name is great
[ __ ] coming to america too was was
good real good
yeah i mean obviously not as awesome as
the first one but it wasn't raining it
was that right yeah well i think that
was the major problem
it was the main difference yeah um
but um
so if he does
if if it comes out an axle foley movie
i think they're
i've heard eddie murphy himself say he
didn't like three
says that we didn't think it was that
good yeah i can't think of a single
person that actually liked three i'm
sure they're out there but so he knows
the deal if you got to do that if you're
going to do four you got to do that [ __ ]
right
which
eddie even though you know he's older
now he's still in good shape
but i mean you can still play that
character because obviously he could
just be like retired and like coming out
of retirement they do a lot of movies
yeah they do a lot of movies like that
right so i don't really see why that
would be a problem yeah and he's usually
working outside the law anyway yeah he's
not in his own so it doesn't matter
right and he in one of the end of at the
end of part one he asked [ __ ]
uh yes uh was it bogamill you think he
asked mobile you think how to quit the
force and become a stay here be a
private detective so that means he
knew about the you know that he
considered being a private detective
that's probably what it'd be like
i yeah that might be a good angle to go
at it from although
people do kind of like
uh him being at odds with you know with
the police authorities because she's
always doing something wrong but
the thing about it is that i think that
in the 80s you could kind of get away
with that because it was a trope
nowadays i don't think you'd get away
with that because it'd be like oh my god
you'd be so fired like if you did that
stuff so i don't think people would
believe it as much but if you were a
private detective you could get around
you could skirt around a lot of those
issues maybe so maybe they should do
that makes sense he'd be a private
detective
yeah i mean that's if i was writing it
which i'm not but if i was writing it
that's that he would be the age where
that's where he would be at this point
yeah when you say graham graham's ex-cop
tammy says i can't even remember if i
saw three i can't either i very well may
have although if it did come out as late
as 1994 then i probably didn't
because that was i was seeing movies in
the theater then but i kind of feel like
my prime
cable watching years were like
early to late 80s
so if it wasn't on cable during that
time i probably didn't see it although i
very well may have you can buy one two
and three on blu-ray in a pack and i
think i only paid around 10 bucks for it
so you know you can get it on amazon
yeah they got it on amazon yeah it's
it's easy to get because like i said
this is like a big this is a big [ __ ]
franchise oh you know what guess what i
did today what'd you do i haven't told
you yet uh-oh i haven't told you is it
something bad it's bad
i bought zardoz on blu-ray
i bet just 35 delivered god damn it yeah
is there a lot of extra [ __ ] on it i
don't know but it's i guess so it was
uh was like 32
but then i had to pay the uh tax on it
and it's a spanish
import will it it's region a b and c oh
okay so it's like i guess that means
region free basically i mean hopefully
and yeah well it has region a and b and
c okay so we'll see and that's that's
really the only thing going and you know
and it was like only ten dollars more
than the dvd
so you might as well just get the
blu-ray version
yeah because y'all didn't get it for me
so you made me spend my whole money
[Laughter]
oh he's guilting everything
out yeah
i didn't know you wanted it i wouldn't i
wanted
yeah
although i got you rome and said we
still haven't watched the end of that we
really need to get around a while it was
season two
yeah we watched the first things yeah
yeah well you know but i like excalibur
a lot and i like to zardoz a lot i
i wish you could
i wish that this would come with a
director's cut
it didn't say it but it'd be neat if
there's a director's cut option that
really omits that [ __ ]
dumbass intro
well i mean you could probably just skip
over it if you really wanted to yeah
it's like the first two minutes or
whatever it is because yeah that is
[ __ ] dumb but other than that it's
like a pretty good it's weird as [ __ ]
but it's like it's pretty good
uh but yeah so uh is that all we have to
say about that oh
beverly hills cop two all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by and uh
we'll be back tomorrow talking about
part three because we're gonna watch
that tonight and see how that goes
wish us luck
[Laughter]
it can't be that bad no it's not it's
just mediocre all right all right so we
will uh see you guys again tomorrow
afternoon slash evening bye